my name is Jonathan Mann aka JT alias
Joey knuckles and is Nicolas cracks
Nicolas scratch because I don't accept
aliens in this period that financial
deterrent power [ __ ]
funny story right into the den let's
give her actually I head off I just have
a five bedroom house you know three cars
in the driveway
a classic 39 that was missing old movies
of classic thirty-nine Plymouth he was
missing one door handle everything else
was completely original down to the
straw in the seats he was still the same
you know he was the car that my father
drove out here hanging field Alabama he
came out to LA looking for work and I
had a house fire
well actually somebody broke into my
house and set it on fire
while I was in Victorville visiting my
kids as I explain to y'all I have 15
kids 13 boys two girls and I was on my
way up to go see my son's mother
as I was getting ready to leave I got a
call at 6:00 in the morning talking
about the fire at the house my mine this
is a big big big big house so I'm
thinking it's like a little bitty you
know something went in the kitchen or
something burned in a trash can a one
wall or the curtain or something sparked
up I said well what did y'all burn
they're like no the whole house I said
the whole house the mighty I'm riding it
right now I screamed so loud I woke up
everybody on the bus because I'm like
how the [ __ ] did you burn down 2.5
million dollar how the [ __ ] did you do
that you know what I'm saying it was
like we was gone we went to the club we
came home the fire department was here
and you know that that was my spiral
downward and there was our years ago 10
I went from making five to seven grand a
week to nothing instantly
all my recording studio equipment burped
crispy you were making money how I owned
the recording studio okay get to my
house I used to work you know me and my
cousin binky binky Womack we worked on
we did and plus I had my own fair share
clientele you know of course my cousin
you know seeing he got the world in that
glass man you know he had the higher
echelon coming the end but he still
always managed to make sure I have
plenty work so like I said we went from
making about five seven grand a week to
nothing to a hotel voucher from it's the
people of Red Cross to that me and an
englis it was devastating because at the
time my son's mother Ramona was pregnant
I think she was about eight months at
the time to newest
it was it was a horrible horrible really
worth it kind of like stripped me
everything I had in because I've never
done really anything other than graffiti
DJ and music that's it that was it I had
been recording music professionally
since 16 so here I was now with no
studio no equipment
no house
I ended up having to sell my classic car
and I couldn't get the price I want like
I said my girls pregnant at the time I
couldn't have us in the street so I
ended up selling what [ __ ] went for
fifty sixty thousand four thousand
dollars because that was the only offer
I was getting so I took that
that money was gone in about two weeks
or so - three weeks
from that it was couched today's couch
to that and eventually we separated I
ended up in
child-custody like battle type [ __ ]
situation with children services want
some smoo gassy [ __ ] that didn't have
[ __ ] to do with me everything to do with
the my own
that put a hold of the toll because now
you know my kids are living with my
sister me and my sister didn't actually
got along since my father died I've
always admired my sister love my sister
to death did everything she ever told me
cuz she was like a second mother you
know but once my father had passed away
the house that I was living in she was
like we're gonna turn this into a frat
house I'm like what about me and my kids
y'all go find someplace else to go
like what you mean we can find somewhere
else to do my time the wanted to carry
this man
I watched him you know pissing blood
going through everything he was gonna do
it I ain't even worried about the phone
let the phone ring
it can't be that important and so
I accept I watched my father period not
this was a man who used to could tighten
car bolts and tires with his bare hands
at the grocery store and drive all the
way home and never have to touch it
again you know he was just always this
big bump burly dude and it's funny
because he worked right down the street
at the river Oh 37 years he worked in
bed two years a vacation time and one
year of sick leave at that point when he
hit 37 and we are begging to take it
take it take it you know just take the
next three years off and just collect
your check and retire but anybody want
he wanted to work and they found the
quickest way to fire me because my
father couldn't read and write me first
came to work for me you have to teach
yourself over the years so when they
computerized everything because he
hadn't got old I think I beg that my
father willed without the mask I was
just the only way he could do it he
couldn't do it with the mask on you have
to deal with the mask off so his eyes
was damaged so
what much he could do you know so they
put him in a two [ __ ] one state put him
in a class to teach you how to computer
and work the computer you know [ __ ] it
all up and didn't press I guess whatever
button II was post the press to log out
that he had passed off the material so
they fired him said he passed out a
million dollars worth of material and
has no way to count for it cut him short
of his pension everything he had coming
broke my father's heart you know sold
after all of this had passed you know I
finally patched things up with my son's
mother
you know I dealt with my loss I didn't
have no insurance so there's nothing I
could do to rebuild
tried to salvage what I could and it's
funny because the only thing that really
survived the fire is I had one wall in
my dining room that was all the bitumen
my uncle my great-grandfather my father
all the important people in my life that
was the only thing survived it didn't
even burn that one wall did not burn
everything else was destroyed
[Music]
and
I worked it out with my son's mother the
normal you know Ramona and I had moved
in with her you know
[Music]
so forth actually first I can win a
victory field where I met an excellent
brother named Mark Sikes gave me a job I
don't know my father
I just was walking down the street and
he stopped me and asked me that I want a
job I mean like the dream should you
imagine like you know nobody ever does
their and he helped me get my little bit
of confidence back and then he even
built a recording studio up there and
Victor bill and I ran it for him but you
know that kind of went south after so
many months because of whatever
technical difficulties he was having
[Music]
I ended up moving to Riverside because I
was having a small problem I'd really a
problem
I got threatened my other baby mom and
she's no joke
so I was slightly scared you know to go
home and so I ended up leaving with my
other sons mother and out to Rialto and
we ended up moving to Riverside
I was there for a while until you went
wild realized that you know it wasn't
working with us I was want to make
myself miserable but this is me having
my own anxiety from not being in my own
house you know I'm still suffering from
that loss inside plus my sister and
father had just died two months apart
from each other
[Music]
I forget exactly how it happened
but I ended up
I ended up back with my son's mother
fear
that was kind of holding some weight you
know she was kind of really ready to
break away from me but you know she had
so much love for me that she wouldn't
just let me be outside like that like
you know so I wasn't fully homeless yet
and then me and her had a daughter my
daughter zenovia say nobody Joyce
Manning if you ever get to see this you
know I love you and I miss you and I
wish I could never let your mama taking
the taxes but
my son but my son's mother my darling
mother explain to me do you know she hid
found a way for her to get you know some
Section eight housing more these
homeless shelters down at this time I'm
living in Riverside he
because you know no woman really wants
her son to be away from his father you
know
if they plan on bringing him up any kind
of manly way to where you can understand
about what a man is supposed to do and
not post it in a proper etiquette of one
night
I'm staying up her up there would hurt
with my daughter's know me you know she
tells me you know she wants to send the
baby to Texas stay with her mother for a
while me and her going to this program
over was the Union rescue mission at the
time and get some housing and all of
this extra actually I really didn't
understand it you know and when I came
down here to look because my father who
worked down here for 37 years told me he
never wanted me downtown gave me horror
stories about how you get snatched and a
hair cut off then all my life so when I
get here I see all these people move on
the sidewalk like you know I'm saying it
I'm like I'm really uncomfortable I'm
edgy but the same time you know
I tend to go overboard so I don't like
to fight it all but you know I was Lily
and I had my other son rolling with me
at the time and he was horrified you
know and I'm telling no condom mankind
don't worry about nothing to stay with
me you know ain't nobody gonna bother
and I ended up I couldn't find her that
day so then I dunno I took him on home
I got the Reposado I came back out with
my daughter and we met right over by the
Union rescue mission and you know she
got inside the program and all this
other little stuff and then she ended up
sending my daughter out and she sent my
daughter out I went back out to
Riverside stay down here all week and
then go home one weekend which
eventually began with him with my
mother-in-law and then you know the
woman I was with started dating a whole
another dude and you know if you ain't
there somebody else gonna shoes
so now I'm downtown permanently sold I'm
thinking temporarily it's gonna be about
six weeks six weeks turned into seven
years you know and needless to say of
course me and my baby mothers broke up
the win right outside anyway she decided
she was gonna take all her anger out on
me for when we originally broke up when
the fire had happened which was three
years prior and she my daughter out to
Texas
I haven't seen this issues about nine
months I have a picture though
I do believe
is her currently right now staying with
at Grambling
and her Uncle David David Richard Wilson
no time goes by and I hear from her
mother that you know it has to take my
daughter to the doctor she had a boil or
some [ __ ] and then I get a call that
they took my daughter and I'm like who
Child Services in Texas my mind this is
my second time in child services in Los
Angeles with a child or the open case
and check-out service case now going on
with her grandma turns out my son's know
my baby mother's brother had been raping
my daughter since she got there
now he was maybe 23 2014 5 years own if
you gave my daughter herpes chlamydia
and HIV so what is she machine to when
they didn't she was finally diagnosed
and Texas laws this is in Texas this is
in Texas Texas laws you don't have to
take a blood test if they come and say
they want to expect everybody can take
everybody to make them take this test
you don't have to do it so they never
prosecuted him in the beginning they
took her mother turned around and tried
to say my daughter was born with it
which [ __ ] me up because I hurried up
and called the social worker said she's
a [ __ ] life and then I ran down
here to JW CH clinic me and her mama
both took HIV test ahead the hospital
sitting and looking at you know the
children people to uh the results and
everything I told him I said see they
lying to your uncle I saying whoever was
around my daughter whoever did it I said
he doing it to wrestling kids to in the
circle you need to test all the kids she
play with and see who it is but her
brother refused to take this test
in the beginning like that's my niece
how the [ __ ] [ __ ] ass police I did
this year it turns out his girlfriend's
daughter she's doing the same thing to
her making her hop the fence at school
and [ __ ] in the truck in his car and
then coming back over the gate she went
into the doctor hall she twists
pregnant herpes chlamydia HIV that's
when they swoop down and grab because
she said that she had been sleeping with
her mother's work and uh that's when
they arrested if you you know you can
you can google that and you'll see for
yourself you see the man they go showing
pictures of my daughter or whatever
that destroyed me
because I didn't know how to handle it
and I had a lot of rage in me
I wanted to may indeed
still want to do
matter of fact he's in Texas
penitentiary system now all of my family
that's in jail right now in Texas are
looking for
and they are doing 16 years of better so
I mean they don't even care if they get
more time for fine cuz you just come you
know you don't ruin the child's life
she'll never have a normal life she can
never have her a decent boy for you you
know how many people you know is though
how many schools and people won't allow
your daughter to play with them you
would have some farm scraper need
it's a lot today I didn't know how to
handle it taking medicine for the rest
of your life from the age of two I
didn't know how to have I did so
I let them go ahead and put her up for
adoption which I'll be great
but I was the Duke it's not nothing to
do I was out here sleeping in a tent
I had no place where to go my mother at
this time had all of my kids already had
for my boys at her house
I couldn't overload her I had no money
to get to Texas plus I was in the middle
of a case myself
so
I try to
work things out my son's mother was
scared
she's feeling worse than me though
because it's her brother you know what
I'm saying but oh I feel like I still
feel like they protect me you know they
even though she was 100% with no you
know my daughter's one with I couldn't
believe my mother had made up that
bullshit-ass though to try to say this
weird all his [ __ ] life we
needed to be able to penitentiary anyway
you know they ended up giving him a life
sentence still think he should have got
the death penalty I don't know I guess
Texas don't do that
that
the lady who had been keeping her
I had the same name as my daughter
I just felt like she was
going to be able to do this it handled a
situation better than me
and is the trip because heart muscle an
angel I have to say
December 16 both born on same day so
kind of like [ __ ] his birthday up for
me but I managed to get through but I do
at that point I'm holding here like a
lot a lot of pen and I searched the
internet and tight ends the dopest
birthday party
then this year I finally got a picture
of her at her birthday party
you know the lady who adopted her same
lady was careful change her name which
really [ __ ] me up seaboard
she was happy since well
I know she don't remember because she
was only like seven died was the last
time I got to see
so now you won't evolve this
all of the stress
and I'm trying to be a man about it and
you know
seemed like them not you know filling
[Music]
the reality you drinking close to 18
beers a day you know
[Music]
because Eli at that point how you know I
couldn't have knew you didn't like that
because Child Services even though I had
a marijuana license because of my back
and show
and I just set out there on the sidewalk
until I met
well I like to call her she was like my
Savior
a young lady my name's Jess
she gave me purpose of you
but like most things you know nothing
ever lasts is and she found out that she
wasn't totally to what the count
deserved the pedestal I was putting but
still she got me closer to God I began
to forgive myself
so she gave you purpose you know I
helped her get her feet off escape from
working you know I encouraged her
everything she does even she works in
Beverly Hills now she gets to wear dress
to work every day you know nice hairdo
was everything you could possibly want
that everything that she had wanted at
the beginning you know who we separated
and that's when I met
precious boobs probably either across
the street or upper one of these
buildings instead of driving me [ __ ]
insane
and so I Anthony Hurley you know but I
watched her go from another addiction
addiction she would usually if she
relapsed it would only last two or three
days
she would be like I wanna go home on one
of your highs please take me home I paid
for a motel that we was living in to
maybe get three four years $65 a day
sounds like 1801 which makes no sense
financially because I said not to put
you in any apartment but this is what
I'm doing paying the day-to-day we're
getting on too so my other child
services case closes he send my kids to
go stay with them up she had developed
to have it and I was telling my mother
and then I said there's some things you
don't know I don't think she's quite
ready yet
you know give her a few more months to
get herself together my mother's does
not believe it you know I've got to be
the scoundrel of course there's no I'm
lying and did whatever whatever so it's
in Mike years ago stag where she is a
getting them took in three months later
after they give meth and he got back
home she just took away
now really destroy you know
I ended up sitting impressions to go
stay with her father when that
he was the best thing for cuz at that
point she was smoking like a burning
building you know it she had to lost all
the way titties no an ass
no she was just you could see her teeth
in her wooden shoes
talking you don't tell just how much
weight was a part of her face
I had got me a motel back on the other
side of town started back when speaking
with jazz on a regular basis you know we
weren't a couple but it was just good
friends you know she was somebody I
could talk to she was like I say like
she was my Savior she got me through I
live or woof mental pictures you know I
always had some kind of say somebody
doing all of this though I'm still
seeing my son's seeing bustin was trying
to get to the ones out and further away
from me you know I got four ended up at
Virginia she was mad I never came back
before ended up it from Riverside to now
in Victorville
then I got another set
my mother's house machining kicked the
two oldest ones out and now a limited
real [ __ ] foster care group homes
I have quarterly 26 actually in this
month
Clark came down here I started selling
her cigarettes
which I really hate it cuz you're not
unlike Nick as a pity I did it and then
you say cigarettes you mean cigarettes
record your it's a pack of cigarettes
regular tobacco cigarettes you know then
despise thing okay
because I mean I even though I hate to
admit this on camera I said probably
never even would have gotten as bad as
it is now if it wasn't for me you know
because they had already banned it from
all the shops but they said he's a
little two dollar containers down here
and you know he defined them that's
right my son's mother started smoking
spice because she couldn't smoke weed so
that's when I noticed the connection and
then it was a shock that I knew that had
and I went up there and they had some of
it three or four shots did you know that
had is that the time I'm gonna say I
didn't know that they had banded yet
it's not a shot so I talked to the
people the way I normally talk you know
I'm the great people's person excellent
sales you know and I ended up getting it
three dollars a bag after three dollars
he was making $45 every three dollars
that you
they get the time it was only maybe one
two three four five people that made up
my little circle but I was the only one
who was getting it at that price you
know and then every now and then it'll
be you know as my partner my like to
call them the basket people they go
dumpster dive and then they find all of
this stuff and they didn't resold it
wasn't as popular yet you know and they
will come and sell us these bags that
they find mean great big all shopping
carts for fifteen twenty dollars oh wow
for real oh yeah here you go that's the
magic number downtown ten dollars you
can give anything to $10 downtown from a
woman to a [ __ ] refrigerator
for ten dollars nine times out of ten
all they want to do is get hot or if
their heroin addict they just want to
get unsick and ten dollars we do it so
we ends up with I mean I think we had a
guy who was selling his bags for a
quarter you know because he was heroin
addict he wasn't his thing but he had so
much of it and he wouldn't tell us where
he was he had nothing another dude the
guy who was selling big shopping carts
for in the rock because he wanted to
have the corner of
and that's kind of when it all began
yes it became that's when I became
addicted to fast money but I have seen
one joint sale for $20 no I've seen a
bag sale for hundred I've seen a guy
comes to you and say you know what I
want 50 bags
I want 20 bag i've seen people spend
their whole check and that's when I
began to realize the side already
reliable not with my son's mother this
[ __ ] was a serious [ __ ] addiction I
don't know what goes on in that dream
they have when they not out but it's
something they don't never want to come
back from
yeah just read like to join me when it
sees about half way goal is to walk back
over to you by now
there was I seen how it working was just
it was too instant an addiction to
instant especially for somebody who
wants to get high but can't get out too
fast under addiction it can almost get
scary to you because they act just like
how crackheads used to act in the haters
you know that searched the ground for
roaches then get beat down in the middle
of the street for picking up a joint out
of somebody box well take a chance than
just run with a handful and get beat up
real bad in the street I didn't sing it
I've seen people try to swim in the
puddle I'm gonna say women stripped butt
naked run down up and down the street I
didn't seen women strip but [ __ ]
naked and taking anyone to be your sex
slave
I don't seen everything happen all for
this party I see him a little fight guys
I have 21-foot Scotty is the atheist
Scotty smoked the spice do it and swore
the sky opened up and God was talking to
him and he met Jesus and here
everybody's he's real did you see him
he's everywhere he's every he said every
time my party was [ __ ] there he said
dude when the hind came down he's came
back and said I kind of heard of it
twice a week I finish talking finished
talking to him because spice I don't
know what it is about it but the high
when you go right back into the same
dream again so you as long as you can
keep the high going you can keep the
dream and I've seen people dream
everything from being basketball players
rappers on stage you're all kind of a
[ __ ] you don't and you get the few to
get stuck in the nightmare
dolls beautiful you know then the ones
that be everywhere a badass got a
comment and then you know people started
getting green you know the guy who was
actually
producing most of what we were using the
sale you know came with a whole other
thing you know and sell your whole key
is two points in power I'm like that key
like for real like dope you're selling
the key come on now I hate is like for
real you know $800 the truth of the
matter is you know I found out later on
they don't cost with maybe one hundred
and something dollars to make the whole
key now you got the next person doing
they got the next person doing now this
person because you know he doesn't have
the issue that the rest of us as
homeless let's get one he's got a house
he's got already got dope money's drug
money you know he's got cocaine money
crystal money hair on money he's buying
big yeah he's getting three four five of
them he's on the corner chopping your
price in half now so now it's not two
dollars anymore it's one dollar you know
all because this greedy person and the
inner circle decided to tell him that so
of course now now the money starts to
shorten up between us
and we looking at them like what are
y'all doing this is supposed to be just
us you know and to be honest with you if
it would have stayed just us everybody
probably be making about five six grand
a day right now and what is spice spice
is
it's basically marshmallow leaf or was
the other one Safran easy to install
[Music]
damiana is there's another source it
really could be anything because
marshmallow leaf is nothing but have you
ever seen those we've the growing your
yard and the winter and a head like this
round leaf own they'll pop up in any
vacant lot you see these trucks in any
of that's the marshmallow so basically
you just got a bag of lawn clippings all
right and you know you you know to shirt
it out to get the dirt up out of it or
whatever and then letting it dry then
you take that and you you spray this
chemical
and you let it dry and then you beg
now it's labeled as an incense which
puts it in a whole nother category
because okay it's not being advertised
at something you smoke
people are just smoking so how do you go
about banning incense
all right you can't really because I
mean the walmart sells it you know it's
in every little shops got a scented
candle or just to stay together you know
this
it's just incense or tea cuz I wasn't
making out of TV this is it's a it's tea
but people are smoking it and get higher
up on it because it was sprayed on it's
very different very different very good
know about me some people you know one
time and that's it for them yeah they
had that one that all this is too strong
because truthfully I had a lot my son's
mother was smoking it so much and she
was not what the [ __ ] this she cannot be
that far am i at the time I'm still
smoking weed you know because our case
had closed at that time no but I was the
first one with my my
move aside in case it just closed so I'm
smoking weed she's still smoking spice
stop and
I hear two tires
this is the living room that over there
with a blue tarp around that's the
kitchen
it took me 45 minutes to make my baby
about
because once it hits you it's not like
you know a gradual upscale high it's BAM
and you're right at the top to me it
kind of felt like you know that feeling
you get when you drunk too much and you
like if I leave left a lot of Obama
that's how it felt to me I didn't like
it at all then I ate some noodles and I
laid down in front of the front door
with the fan on trying to make the hi
come down then I thought I hear a [ __ ]
like I hear people plotting on me
outside the door and then when I open
the door is crickets ain't nobody
outside I know and I closed the door it
start right back open the door stop
close the door and start right back over
the door and stop so I open the door
leave it open and there further face
when that [ __ ] more often yeah that
could hurt us that how the [ __ ] is this
not illegal you've got to be kidding me
this is nothing this needs to be illegal
you know but you can see the street for
people that are the most out of their
minds they're smoking spice
you know that's really a combination of
mental illness and the dream you know
everybody talking they going to this
dream right
I know guy who just this he's did I just
found this out this is before I came
back I left it Jenny where like I told
you because I hopes going on and though
he's sitting in his room smoking myself
and I guess you know sometimes do you
know the higher make you not know where
you are but then you panic and he jumped
out his window six stories up
[ __ ] me up when I heard I was like that
nothin here inside the happy lady don't
yeah but Center Street no right on 6th
Street the SRO yeah except his name was
a drill drill used to be a dancer you
see one of the business that was this
thing he wanted to be on who can dance
so whatever the little show is I was his
gold second he started smoking that [ __ ]
don't out the window
he couldn't even function him just be
sitting there you couldn't move these
are swore you can still do this and do
that I said that you came you sitting in
his [ __ ] spice coma all David and his
whole thing doing go watch his woman
leaving everything else in there by
herself long as he had spikes he didn't
get me [ __ ] spend his whole entire
checkup and still get credit after that
you know but kinda in the beginning to
me that was the best part until I began
to realize what was going on because he
would be doing so I owe you $750 $800
$300 $400 so when check days came even
you'd had so much money in your pocket
you wouldn't even want to sit out there
to fail done hey I'm gone I'm gonna go
see my kids you know they talk
collecting on these guys nah
yeah but me it was different because for
every joints you got on credit for me
and you because I would charge $10 for
one joint on credit period that was it
because I didn't want to do it because I
had a hotel bill out with pain plus I in
child support on southerners [ __ ] I had
the money to issue out this I never
really wanted to do it but when they
started grinning to it I was like are
you sure about that I'm not gonna have
to hunt you down and nothing they're
like no it's not right so you'll have a
dual credit 75 room when he shows back
up that he pays the $750 to you I give
him a whole nother 75 Joey's for free
this is a paying your bill so in his
eyes he lightweight kind of feel like he
won because now I got huevos spiced and
I didn't even know he was gonna give me
this 50 40 enjoy extra choice so he's
happened yeah well what happens he
smokes one falls asleep wakes up and his
friends they were sitting there around
him and took everything else wrong and I
think at that point I think the most out
of made was I think 1,200
and that was really bizarre to me scared
the [ __ ] out of me because it was $1.00
joints in like 1200 times I don't with
handing a hand 1202 times in one day and
that's when it became people started
making their own spice
which is absurd because they only knew
two ingredients and didn't know 30 so
you got guys who's putting nail polish
remover on marshmallow leaf because you
can buy a key of marshmallow leaf $78
for the whole key you get nail polish
remover for three dollars you soak the
whole batch and then they're putting
formaldehyde
on to the on to spraynet on this is look
made that triage happened down there
wait ahead filled up all these emergency
rules and that 15 Pete had to open one
in the middle of the street in San Pedro
the 15 people died behind that and the
dude who had it kept old selling it
Keppel 17 that those who were like
hardcore smokers we call them black
fingers because they have black
fingertips because from smoking roaches
that I mean black black black I mean
blue black like like that barked up meat
really and those cats were okay it was
just like it's strong as hell but those
who were at that level had their
tolerance level they were dropping off
that night didn't with people who was
going until they would hold this moment
and nobody was there
saved them we'll call the ambulance for
them while he was in their sorrows you
know and so they just recently gave a
guy they they gave him 30 years and they
pinned it all over them
but I have been telling everybody for
longest after that had happened that it
was a federal crime
is that y'all thinking that y'all coming
out here and y'all sitting in front of
ponies rolling I mean all up and down
the street y'all just sitting there
where all of these joints like you're
not gonna go to jail it's a federal
crime you know and then I had met this
guy named Joe and Joe introduced me to
his young white guy he was about maybe
26 something 26 dead been in business 3
years made 40 million dollars selling he
was a manufacturer distributor he had a
warehouse and you know 40 million three
years at house in Calabasas Ferrari
Rolls Royces you know you should take g5
flights I've seen the order list the
order lists will come in to be eight
thousand ten thousand twelve thousand
seven hundred here and there it was
amazing the money that was coming to him
you know hand over fist and he was
shocked to itself you know but
whenever they came up with a law to say
okay we're banning this chemical can't
use this anymore it's illegal federally
bank now so now you can't have that but
if you're a manufacturer distributor you
own this company business license you
registered warehouse everything the
government sends you a paper that says
this chemical is now banned for a
substitute you can use and they'll give
you three to five things yeah but this
guy I'd say it was very lucrative for
him using bide by all the rules state
California said to me but his orders
were coming from out of state you know
and other states were having the same
issue - a lot of people didn't know it
because it was like they were kind of
keeping it under wraps but I think about
all 50 states now have an issue with you
know and so you've got a company in
Detroit they want eight thousand dollars
worth of product because they're doing
so well out there it's been the 8,000
you got a company in Florida they want
to spend 20,000 you got these people
over here in Des Moines Idaho they got
50,000 they want to spend so money is
coming to him left hand foot hand foot
from legal tobacco shops that are seven
spice and and he's a legal producer of
[ __ ] but his flaw was chemicals that are
banned in California that you bought the
ones you can use don't necessarily mean
they're not banned in another state
so he's mailing this stuff out to the
people just conducting business as usual
and they came and raided the warehouse
snatched him at his house in Calabasas
froze his bank accounts resting and told
him you know he was under arrest for
sales and distribution of synthetic
marijuana folks looking for spices and
he's like that's impossible
yeah I've run the factory I'm legally
federally licensed to do this this time
yeah this is [ __ ] so you know when
you go to court they tell him you know
the deal is 20 years Vince like 20 I'm
not doing 20 years my news to me three
alone you know 26 at the time
23 is when you open the cup 26 years old
at the time
I'm an eagle I'm not doing any golden
higher than the best lawyer you can
everything up there was nothing he could
do a lot so he fought the case and
everything he was trying to say that he
was gonna use a first defense failed
against him so he ended up giving him 30
years in federal pen stripped him all
his money all his cars everything gone
[Music]
and we don't say I took a hiatus for
three months because II was I was I was
going through too much but you know
I wasn't getting along with any of my
kids mothers anymore my lizards like
somebody started undercutting my
business it's time you know it was a
gentleman that I've known for more than
ten years at one point he was even
taking care of my kids for me you know
cut into my money really bad so I went
from making about eight hundred dollars
a day to making one hundred dollars a
day and it really affected me and one of
my mentors from childhood and those both
loved us and he told me this word as he
possibly could he said it's a sidewalk I
can't stop what goes on on a sidewalk
you can't claim anything because it's
not yours I said it's [ __ ] up that
your friends is the one that's doing
this to you he said but now you know
he's not your friend so you have a
choice to make yourself you say do you
do something that's gonna cause you know
bad vibes in retaliation to yourself or
do you just continue to be you
time to continue to be me so I dealt
with you know this cause you know
riffles between me and my son's mother
because they was agreeing and now
they're fine they're all agreed to bring
my kids you know to my mother's house
every weekend you know and kids was all
getting brand-new stuff everything that
they needed I was like you know I was a
good father once again even though what
I was doing wasn't completely legal or
illegal at the time because they had
made that the law yeah I was at peace
you know then that got snatched from me
I fell behind on child support
understand I didn't do this I didn't do
that I'm just trying to tell her you
know understand I want to be here I just
want some peace I need to do what I want
to do you know my two friends that just
passed away and I was sitting there and
I was thinking to myself I've really
been on this corner you know almost
downtown periods I'm out six seven years
I could have really just the same
struggle I did I could have went to
college and had my degree in been two
years on the job that I had trained for
and then that's when I realized you know
I had a conversation with my mother she
was like I'm 77 years old
I don't want to be in California don't
want to go back to Alabama they said but
I can't cuz I got two kids and that's
when I said I got to get myself back
reunited with my mother you know and I
spent that time around my mother too you
know she thought it would be me instead
doesn't you don't you think you might
want to go out and sales and don't do
something other than be right here and I
had to take it for what it was worth I
mean she dealt with me for a month you
know during the cold rainy part of the
winter she sat roles our electricity
bill up $700 nothing with the floor he
drew that should've do it to you and
I ended up right back down here